Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It won't be easy You'll think it's strange When I try to explain how I feel That I still need your love to all that I've done You won't believe me All you will see is a girl you once knew
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这并不容易，当你试图解释我的感受时，你会觉得这很怪异，我对你曾经做过的一切仍然需要你的爱，你不会相信我，你看到的只是一个你曾经认识的女孩
Although she's dressed up to the nines At sixes and sevens with you. I had to let it happen. I had to change. Couldn't stay all my life down at heel. Looking out of the window, staying out of the sun. So I chose
尽管她盛装打扮，却和你意见不合、不知所措。我不得不顺其自然。我不得不改变。不能一辈子都这般落魄。向窗外望去，远离阳光。所以我选择了
freedom. Running around, trying everything new, but nothing impressed me at all. I never expected it to. Don't cry for me, Argentina. The truth is I never left you. Through my wild days. Mad existence. I kept my promise.
自由。四处奔走，尝试所有新鲜事物，但没有一样能打动我。我从未指望过它能打动我。不要为我哭泣，阿根廷。事实是，我从未离开过你。在我疯狂的日子里。疯狂的存在。我信守了诺言。
Don't keep your distance. Don't keep your distance. So, Dominic, that was Madonna playing Evita in the Miami mix of Don't Cry For Me, Argentina, written, of course, by Andrew Lloyd Webber and Tim Rice. Tom, what happened to Madonna's voice? Could you tell? It was actually me. Was she singing in a Spanish accent? Is that deliberate? No, that was American. Oh really, that was American? Yeah, it was an American accent. You could tell. Could you? Anyway, so today we are looking at Eva Peron, aka Evita. Yeah.
不要保持距离。不要保持距离。好了，多米尼克，刚才那是麦当娜在迈阿密混音版的《阿根廷，不要为我哭泣》中饰演艾薇塔，这首歌当然是由安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯和蒂姆·赖斯创作的。汤姆，麦当娜的声音怎么了？你听得出来吗？其实那是我的声音。她是在用西班牙语口音唱歌吗？那是故意的吗？不，那是美式口音。哦真的吗，那是美式口音？对，那是美式口音。听得出来。是吗？无论如何，今天我们要探讨的是伊娃·庇隆，也就是艾薇塔。对。
And she has a place in my heart. And that particular track has a place in my heart. Oh, that's nice. Did you ever see the film? I did. So it came out just after Christmas. And you may remember in the episode we did on disco. Yes.
她在我的心中占有一席之地。而那首歌在我的心中也占有一席之地。哦，那真不错。你看过那部电影吗？我看过。它在圣诞节后不久上映。你可能还记得我们在关于迪斯科的那期节目中讲过。是的。
I mentioned that Sadie and I were great habituates of love muscle. Yeah. At the fridge in Brixton. Yeah. And the film Evita came out i think a couple of days after christmas and there was a rumor that there was going to be a big evita night to celebrate it coming out at the fridge at love muscle and the rumor was that madonna herself was going to turn up cranky so we drove all the way back from where we'd been staying christmas to
我提到过萨迪和我是“爱之肌”（Love Muscle）的常客。是的。就在布里克斯顿的“冰箱”夜总会。是的。电影《艾薇塔》上映，我想是在圣诞节后几天，当时有传言说“冰箱”夜总会的“爱之肌”会举办一场盛大的艾薇塔之夜来庆祝它的上映，传言说麦当娜本人会大驾光临，简直让人抓狂，所以我们从过圣诞节的地方开车一路赶回
go to it dressed up in our glad rags and went to the night what did you dress as evita yeah evita or colonel peron i can't remember one of the two i mean you would remember that tom so that suggests that you did dress as a vita anyway let's move on and we went there and of course madonna didn't turn up no but it was a brilliant brilliant evening you know they sang that they sang all kinds of other stuff and they had people in the crowds with peronist slogans waving it around and i remember thinking this is completely mad what other figure from south american history would inspire a night like this i'd go to a simon bolivar night they don't hold it that in brixton they didn't have it no and so as a result of that i didn't really know anything about evita but i read about her a lot over the following year and of course the film and the musical opens with Evita's funeral, where everyone is terribly upset.
去参加，盛装打扮去了那个派对。你打扮成什么了？艾薇塔？对，艾薇塔还是庇隆将军？我不记得了，二选一。我的意思是，汤姆，你会记得的，这说明你确实打扮成了艾薇塔。不管怎样，我们继续吧。我们去了那里，当然麦当娜没有出现。没有，但那是一个极其精彩的夜晚，你知道的，他们唱了那首歌，还唱了各种其他歌曲，人群中有人拿着庇隆主义的标语到处挥舞，我当时想，这简直太疯狂了。南美历史上有哪位其他人物能激发这样的一场派对？我会去参加西蒙·玻利瓦尔之夜吗？布里克斯顿可不办这个，他们没办过。所以因此，我对艾薇塔其实一无所知，但在接下来的一年里我读了很多关于她的书，当然，电影和音乐剧开场就是艾薇塔的葬礼，每个人都难过得不得了。
And of course, 1997, which is the year of Diana's death, was the perfect year to be reading about Evita. It's true. It's a good point. Tom, well, first of all, that is a lovely story. Thank you. And it gives us some wonderful insights, I think, into the cult of Evita and Argentine history. Yeah. But also, Tom, you're in very good company. Because do you know who you remind me of?
当然，1997年，也就是戴安娜王妃去世的那一年，正是阅读艾薇塔的最佳年份。确实如此。说得好。汤姆，首先，这是一个很棒的故事。谢谢你。我认为，这让我们对艾薇塔的个人崇拜和阿根廷历史有了极好的见解。是的。但同时，汤姆，你也是同行中人。因为你知道你让我想起了谁吗？
Who also went out of their way to engage with the cult of Evita, to go to a performance that would be Evita-themed in London like you. And somebody with whom you've often been compared, actually. Would it be the Iron Lady by any chance? It would be the Iron Lady. So in August 1978, Margaret Thatcher went to see Evita with her speechwriter, Ronnie Miller. So the Andrew Lord Webber musical. And after she got back, she wrote Ronnie Miller a letter,
是谁也曾大费周章地去参与对艾薇塔的崇拜，像你一样去伦敦看一场以艾薇塔为主题的演出。而且，实际上，这个人经常被拿来与你作比较。莫非是铁娘子吗？正是铁娘子。因此，在1978年8月，玛格丽特·撒切尔和她的演讲撰稿人罗尼·米勒一起去看了《艾薇塔》。也就是安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯的音乐剧。她回去后，给罗尼·米勒写了一封信，
which is in her archive. And it says, Dear Ronnie, it was a strangely wondrous evening yesterday, leaving so much to think about. I still find myself rather disturbed by it. Which is exactly how a lot of listeners to this podcast would be feeling, Tom, having listened to your singing.
这封信保存在她的档案里。信中写道：“亲爱的罗尼，昨天是一个奇妙而又奇异的夜晚，留下了太多让人思考的东西。我发现自己至今仍对它感到有些不安。”汤姆，听了你的歌声，这正是本播客的许多听众现在的感受。
And she says, now, if they can do that without any ideals, then if we apply the same perfection and creativeness to our message, we should provide good historic material for an opera called Margaret in 30 years time. So you are the Iron Lady of this podcast, are you not? She's being harsh there i
她说：“现在，如果他们能在没有任何理想的情况下做到这一点，那么如果我们把同样的完美和创造力运用到我们的信息中去，我们应该能为30年后一部名为《玛格丽特》的歌剧提供很好的历史素材。”所以你是本播客的铁娘子，不是吗？撒切尔夫人在这点上对艾薇塔的评价
think mrs thatcher on evita because i think evita did have ideals she did indeed but i mean i think actually the parallels between evita and mrs thatcher on one level absolutely mad they're opposite ends of the political spectrum yeah but on the other i'm looking forward to this the devotion to i suppose to kind of taking center stage and playing the diva which is of course what the andrew lloyd weber musical is all about it's kind of playing with riffs of opera the tragic heroine and all that kind of thing yeah of course and both avita and mrs satchel were very good at playing the diva and also both of them were simultaneously loved and hated they were and it's a perfect example of how a female politician or political figure generally, I would say, elicits stronger reactions than a man does.
可能有点苛刻，因为我认为艾薇塔确实有理想，她确实有。但我的意思是，实际上我认为艾薇塔和撒切尔夫人之间的相似之处在某种程度上简直疯狂，她们处于政治光谱的对立面。是的，但另一方面，我很期待这一点，那就是对——我想——成为焦点并扮演极具个性的大牌女性的这种执着，这当然正是安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯的音乐剧所关注的全部内容，它有点像是在玩弄歌剧的桥段、悲剧女主角以及所有诸如此类的东西。当然，艾薇塔和撒切尔夫人都非常擅长扮演万人迷和女主角，而且她们都同时被爱戴和痛恨。确实如此，这是一个完美的例子，说明了女性政治家或通常的女性政治人物——我想说——比男性更能引起强烈的反应。
Extreme reactions. Of course, but there have been lots of female leaders indeed in Argentina. Yeah, Cristina Kirchner. Yeah, but I think that Evita and Mrs. Thatcher are probably the most diva-esque female political leaders since the war, wouldn't you say? Since the war of the 20th century, I would say, Tom, with no question. Evita is easily one of the most famous female public figures of the 20th century, probably Mrs Thatcher
极端的反应。当然，不过阿根廷确实有过很多女性领导人。是的，克里斯蒂娜·基什内尔。是的，但我认为自战后以来，艾薇塔和撒切尔夫人可能是最具“女主角”风范的女性政治领导人，你觉得呢？汤姆，毫无疑问，自20世纪战后以来就是如此。艾薇塔无疑是20世纪最著名的女性公众人物之一，可能撒切尔夫人也是，
and Indira Gandhi, I guess, or Golda Meir in Israel. But they haven't had a smash hit musical written about them. No, and the fact that she had a musical written about her is very revealing she was a creature of show business because she was an actress yes as we will discuss it's not just her performance but her politics is enormously informed by the soap opera melodramas that she embodied on the radio and in that sense i think there's actually a comparison with ronald reagan in america when we did our reagan series we talked about how Reagan's worldview, his sense of himself, the message he took to American voters was really strongly informed by his time in Hollywood. The Hollywood thing wasn't a joke or an accident. It was really important. show business background in the 1930s and 1940s actually is her politics in a weird way and that sort of cult of the spectacle and of performance and sentimentality has been at the heart of
还有印地安娜·甘地，我想，或者以色列的果尔达·梅厄。但人们没有为她们写过大红大紫的音乐剧。是的，她拥有一部以她为主角的音乐剧，这一事实非常具有启示意义，她是一个属于娱乐圈的人，因为她曾是一名演员。是的，正如我们将要讨论的那样，不仅是她的表演，她的政治生涯在很大程度上也受到了她在广播中体现的肥皂剧和情节剧的影响。从这个意义上讲，我认为这实际上可以与美国的罗纳德·里根进行比较。当我们制作里根系列节目时，我们谈到里根的世界观、他对自己的认知以及他带给美国选民的信息，其实很大程度上都受到了他在好莱坞那段经历的影响。好莱坞的经历并非笑话或偶然。它真的很重要。她20世纪30年代和40年代的娱乐圈背景，在某种程度上实际上构成了她的政治。这种对奇观、表演和感伤的崇拜一直是
argentine politics yeah ever since and there's also a further dimension which you don't get with thatch and reagan which is the catholic dimension yeah because santa rivita as she's hailed both in the musical and on the streets of Buenos Aires when she was the star of the show, that is a genuine expression. When she died, there were moves to have her canonised. There were, absolutely. Which the Vatican rejected for reasons that we will explore. But obviously, the sense of drama that public displays of Catholic ritual have is something else that is a part of the Evita mythos and just makes her an amazing, amazing subject. Agreed, Tom.
阿根廷政治的核心所在，是的，一直如此。此外还有一个更深层次的维度，这是撒切尔和里根身上所没有的，那就是天主教的维度。是的，因为正如她在音乐剧以及当年作为风云人物在布宜诺斯艾利斯街头所受到的欢呼一样，她被尊为“圣伊娃”，这是一种真挚的情感表达。她去世时，曾有人动议将她封圣。是的，确有其事。但梵蒂冈拒绝了这一请求，原因我们将会探讨。但很显然，天主教仪式公开展示所带来的戏剧感，正是艾薇塔神话的组成部分之一，这也让她成为了一个令人惊叹、无与伦比的研究对象。完全同意，汤姆。
So that's what we're going to do today. It reminds me a little bit. We did an episode about the Saint Catherine of Siena, who's suffering and who's sort of self-mortification, who's visible suffering. The fact that she embraces people who are deeply deeply ill and all of that kind of thing so there's a thing isn't there she kisses a leper avita kisses a leper yes and someone rushes forward and tries to swab her lips with alcohol she smashes the bottle yes and she says no you know these are my people you could say she's the link between katharine sienna and diana who you mentioned she's also as i hope we will show, she's the link between Catherine of Siena and Donald Trump.
所以这就是我们今天要做的。这让我想起了一点。我们曾做过一期关于锡耶纳的圣凯瑟琳的节目，她的苦难，她的某种自我克制，她那看得见的苦难。她拥抱那些病入膏肓的人等等诸如此类的事情，所以这里有一种现象，不是吗？她亲吻了一个麻风病人。艾薇塔亲吻了一个麻风病人，是的。然后有人冲上前去试图用酒精擦拭她的嘴唇，她打碎了瓶子，是的，她说：“不，你知道的，这些人是我的人民。”你可以说她是锡耶纳的凯瑟琳和刚才你提到的戴安娜之间的纽带，正如我希望我们所展示的那样，她也是锡耶纳的凯瑟琳和唐纳德·特朗普之间的纽带。
Her politics are not the same as Donald Trump's, but we will see how... She's all about the vibe, isn't she? The vibe, the style. Politics as style. So, it's an amazing story, and we'll be doing it in the course of this week. Evita's background, her rise,
她的政治立场与唐纳德·特朗普不同，但我们会看到……她完全讲究那种气场，不是吗？气场，风格。将政治视为一种风格。所以，这是一个惊人的故事，我们将在本周的节目中探讨。艾薇塔的背景、她的崛起，
her relationship with Peron, her extraordinary death, and the way in which that becomes this public melodrama. And then the even more bizarre story. Yeah, that's really mad. About what happens next to her body, to her reputation, to her ghost, and the attempts of people to basically be Evita in the 1970s, amid the chaos of Argentine sort of politics with terrorism and bombings.
她与庇隆的关系，她非同寻常的死，以及那如何演变成了一场公众情节剧。还有更离奇的故事。是的，那真的太疯狂了。关于她的遗体、她的声誉、她的幽灵后来遭遇了什么，以及在20世纪70年代阿根廷政治动荡、恐怖主义和炸弹袭击的混乱中，人们试图模仿艾薇塔的种种举动。
And it is the most amazing story. Let's start, obviously obviously with the woman and her background. So we are in Argentina in the late 1910s and I think you know we can't spend ages on all this but just to give you four things I think it's important to have in our heads about Argentina. First of all Argentina is par excellence the country of immigrants so in her lifetime its population almost quadrupled and these are people who are quite poor, often, coming from Italy, Spain, and Germany. During her early years, probably a third of the Argentine population had been born overseas. They had arrived in Argentina because it's the promised land.
这绝对是最精彩的故事。很显然，让我们从这位女性和她的背景开始讲起。所以我们来到了20世纪10年代末的阿根廷，我想，虽然我们不能把时间全花在这些上面，但只要列出关于阿根廷你必须了解的四点，我认为很重要。首先，阿根廷可以说是典型的移民国家，在她的一生中，人口几乎翻了两番。这些人往往比较穷，来自意大利、西班牙和德国。在她早年的时候，阿根廷大约三分之一的人口是在海外出生的。他们来到阿根廷，是因为这里是乐土。
Great hopes for this wonderful new life, this utopian world into which they are coming. Which is a rich and prosperous country, isn't it? It's a very rich and prosperous country. But of course, the thing is, you arrive somewhere with great ambitions, you are very easily frustrated if it doesn't work out. Yeah. And you look for someone to blame. Well, in the words of Jimmy Nail, Ava, beware of the city. Jimmy Nail.
对这种美妙的新生活、对他们即将进入的乌托邦世界抱有巨大的希望。这是一个富裕而繁荣的国家，对吧？这是一个非常富裕和繁荣的国家。但当然，问题在于，当你怀着宏大的抱负来到一个地方时，如果事情没有成功，你就会很容易感到沮丧。是的。然后你会寻找替罪羊。嗯，用吉米·内尔（Jimmy Nail）的话来说：“爱娃，当心这座城市。”吉米·内尔。
I didn't think we'd have Jimmy Nail on the podcast. That's nice. Our friend of the show, Dan Jackson, will enjoy that. Number two, Argentina is a country dominated by one city buenos aires huge port it looks out to the old world and particularly to britain actually it's integrated into british imperial economic networks and behind it is this vast agricultural hinterland the pampas which is where she comes from and a lot of the people who are kind of the ruling classes the oligarchic classes are either brit British or very influenced
我没想到我们在播客里会提到吉米·内尔。这真不错。我们的节目之友丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）会喜欢的。第二点，阿根廷是一个由单一城市——布宜诺斯艾利斯主导的国家，它拥有巨大的港口，面向旧世界，尤其是面向英国，实际上它已经融入了英国的帝国经济网络。而在它的背后，则是广袤的农业腹地——彭巴草原，她就出身于此。许多属于统治阶级或寡头阶级的人，要么是英国人，要么深受
by Britain. I mean, that's how football becomes so huge. Exactly. So football, polo, rugby, we'll discuss some of this later on. So it's important to sort of remember that. The third thing, I think, is that Argentina, uniquely, even in Latin America, it looks to Europe, it sees itself as a kind of a European country. It had a very small population of African slaves who ended up being completely assimilated. The Indian indigenous population, so-called Indian, largely extinct, but very few of them left. So they're very European. They're always looking to Europe, but at the same time, they're very conscious of being out on the complete margins, the very bottom of South America. And there's a sense, I think, lots of sort of political
由英国引入。我的意思是，这就是足球变得如此受欢迎的原因。没错。所以足球、马球、橄榄球，我们稍后会讨论其中的一部分。所以记住这一点很重要。第三点，我认为，阿根廷独特的地方在于，即便在拉丁美洲也是如此，它面向欧洲，将自己视为一个某种程度上的欧洲国家。它曾有极少数的非洲奴隶人口，最终完全被同化了。印第安原住民人口，也就是所谓的印第安人，大体上已经消亡，只剩下极少数。所以他们非常欧洲化。他们总是向往欧洲，但与此同时，他们又非常清楚自己身处彻底的边缘，位于南美洲的最南端。而且有一种感觉，我认为，有很多类似政治上的
scientists have written about this. There's a sense of a desire to emulate Europe and particularly Britain, but also a sense of being snubbed and being forgotten and put down. And I think that's really important. And then the fourth thing is that Argentina has always had a history of very deep division and inequality. So throughout the 19th century, during its first century of independence, it was torn apart by endless civil wars between Unitarians who were centralists in Buenos Aires and Federalists, you know, the landowners who wanted to keep their power out in the provinces. And then later on, you have a great deal of tension
学者都写过这方面的文章。有一种效仿欧洲尤其是英国的渴望，但同时也有一种被冷落、被遗忘和被打压的感觉。我认为这非常重要。第四点，阿根廷一直有着极度分裂和不平等的历史。因此，在整个19世纪，在其独立后的第一个世纪里，它被布宜诺斯艾利斯的中央集权主义者（即一元论者）与想要在各省保持权力的土地所有者（即联邦主义者）之间无休止的内战撕裂了。后来，你又会发现，以马球阶层为基础的旧有土地精英与日益庞大的城市工人阶层之间存在着大量的紧张关系。所以，这就是关于阿根廷政治背景你真正需要了解的一切。好吧，这并非你全部需要了解的，但为了本播客的目的，这就是你所需要知道的一切，当然还有更多可以说的，不是吗？不过，就目前而言，未来的爱娃·庇隆出生在阿根廷中部一个名不见经传的小地方，名叫洛斯托尔多斯（Los Toldos），距离布宜诺斯艾利斯150英里，时间是1919年5月。这个地名意思是“帐篷”，对吧？所以它有点暗指那里曾经存在过的土著营地。
between the old landed elites that based the polo set and this swelling mass of urban workers. So that's all you need to know, really, about the background to Argentine politics. Well, it's not all you need to know, but it's all you need to know for the purposes of the podcast there is more to say isn't there but yeah for now so ava perron as she becomes is born in this nothing place called los tolos in the sort of middle of argentina 150 miles from buenos aires in may 1990 and that means the tents doesn't it so it's a kind of an allusion to the kind of the native encampment that had once been there.
正是如此。在她成长的时候，村子外面应该还住着一小撮住在简陋棚屋、也就是窝棚里的原住民。每逢节庆日，你还能看到他们披着彭巴斗篷到处骑马。但总的来说，这是一个由农场工人和农业劳动力组成的村庄。那里没什么可做的，对吧？那里确实无事可做，所以主要的运动是斗鸡。如果你喜欢斗鸡的话，对吧，我的意思是，也许那还不错；但除此之外，如果你不喜欢斗鸡，那真是字面意义上无事可做。
It is, exactly. When she was growing up, there would have been a handful of native people living in hovels, sort of shacks outside the village. And you would see them at feast days kind of riding around in their ponchos and stuff. But by and large, it's a village of farm workers, farm labourers. There's not a lot to do there is there there's nothing to do so the big sport is cockfighting so if you like cockfighting yeah i mean maybe that's good but otherwise if you don't like cockfighting there's literally nothing
我想，即使你喜欢斗鸡，也有比这更好的地方。是的，待久了会有点无聊。所以她的父亲是一个名叫胡安·杜阿尔特（Juan Duarte）的43岁男子，他来自20英里外的一个小镇。他是一名庄园经理。他没有和她的母亲结婚。所以他四十多岁了。她的母亲是一个名叫胡安娜·伊巴古伦（Juana Ibarguren）的巴斯克女性。就像阿斯顿维拉的主教练乌奈·埃梅里（Unai Emery）一样。哦，谢谢。这挺好。
to do i think even if you like cockfighting there are better places to be yeah it gets a bit boring after a while so her father is a man called juan duarte who's 43 and he comes from a town 20 miles away. And he works as an estate manager. He's not married to her mother. So he's in his 40s. Her mother is a woman called Juana Ibarguren, who's a Basque. Like Unai Emery, the manager of Aston Villa. Oh, thanks. That's nice.
就像乌奈·埃梅里一样。是的。或者是前狼队主教练于伦·洛佩特吉（Julen Lopetegui）。是的。我的意思是，世界上有很多巴斯克人。是的，他们无处不在，洛佩特吉。是的，我的意思是，世界上有很多巴斯克人。是的，他们到处都是，巴斯克人。
Like Unai Emery. Yeah. Or the former Wolves manager, Julen Lopetegui. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there's loads of Basques in the world. Yeah. They're everywhere,etegui. Yeah. I mean, there's loads of Basques in the world. Yeah. They're everywhere, the Basques.
太棒了。她的母亲在大约15岁时遇到了杜阿尔特，并为他生了四个孩子。不幸的是，在本系列节目中，这并不是最后一次出现年龄差距大得令人警惕的恋爱关系，我认为这样说很公平。现在，杜阿尔特其实已经结过婚，在别处有家室。他来到洛斯托尔多斯这个小镇担任某种农场经理。正如当时阿根廷非常普遍的那样，他基本上拥有了第二段婚姻。因为他离第一任妻子很远。
Wonderful. Her mother had met Duarte when she was probably about 15 and bore him four children. This is not, unfortunately, the last time in this series that there will be relationships with an alarmingly large age gap, I think it's fair to say. Now, Duarte is actually married and has a family elsewhere. He comes to this town, Los Toldos, to work as a sort of farm manager. And as is very common in Argentina in those days, he basically has a second marriage. Because he's a long way from his first wife.
他离第一任妻子很远。起初，通常这种关系会和一个原住民女性、一个本地女性在一起。但随着时间的推移，情况有所演变。于是他有了胡安娜。有趣的是，她显然是一个非常骄傲、有野心且顽固的女性。嗯，那将是她的巴斯克血统，多米尼克。哦，当然。巴斯克人是非常骄傲的人。
He's a long way from his first. And at first, the norm was this would be with an indigenous woman, a native woman. But over time, it kind of evolves. So he has Juana. Interestingly, she's clearly a very proud, ambitious and stubborn woman. Well, that will be her Basque heritage, Dominic. Oh, of course. They're very proud people, the Basques.
他们是骄傲的人。骄傲而独立。是的。她随了他的姓，这很不寻常。她自称为杜阿尔特。村里的人不喜欢她。目前还不清楚他们是觉得她在和一个大人物睡觉从而嫉妒她，还是因为她这样做而鄙视她。也许两者兼而有之。她算是个不断向上流动的人，对吧？而且带有不止一丝的势利。是的。因此，她一方面看不起那些有理由看不起她的人，而那里又除了斗鸡之外无事可做。我的意思是，
They are proud people. Proud and independent. Yes. She takes his name, which is unusual. She calls herself Duarte. People in the village don't like her. It's not clear whether they think she's sleeping with a big man, so they envy her, or whether they despise her for doing this. Maybe a bit of both. She's kind of upwardly mobile, isn't she? And with more than a hint of snobbery. Yeah. And so the fact that she's simultaneously looking down on people who have reason to look down on her, and there's nothing to do except cockfighting. I mean,
这绝对是一场噩梦，不是吗？确实如此。从本质上讲，人们会在背后说她的闲话。他们确实如此。他们也确实这么做了。现在，爱娃的出生证明将在后续剧集中出现，随之而来的还有关于出生证明的非常复杂的问题。目前看来很清楚的是，她的出生证明后来出于我们将要解释的原因被销毁了。但在当时，看过它的人说，她的姓氏不是她父亲的姓氏杜阿尔特，而是她母亲的姓氏伊巴古伦（Ibargirin）。
it's an absolute nightmare, isn't it? It is. I mean, essentially, people are going to bitch about her. They are indeed. And they do. Yes. Now, Ava's birth certificate will come a little bit later in a subsequent episode to the very complicated issue of the birth certificate. What it seems pretty clear is that her birth certificate was later destroyed for reasons that we will explain. But at the time, people who saw it said that her surname was not given as Duarte, her father's surname, but as her mother's surname, Ibargirin.
村里有很多流言蜚语。两人为此大吵过一架，这也是爱娃的出生登记被严重拖延的原因。她是第四个孩子。她有两个姐姐和一个哥哥胡安。很显然，孩子们和母亲坚持要继续使用胡安·杜阿尔特的名字，尽管他并不想让他们这么用，
And there was a lot of gossip in the village. There had been a massive row about this between the two of them, which is why there'd been a big delay in registering Ava's birth. She's the fourth child. She's got two elder sisters and one elder brother, Juan. And what is clear is that the children and the mother insisted that they would continue using Juan Duarte's name, even though he didn't want them to,
而且他们也没有法律上的资格。所以从一开始，我就觉得有一种污点存在。她的父母没有结婚，而且她使用的是一个不属于她名字的姓氏。但同时也有着一种向上流动、渴望、想要比自己出身更好的追求。绝对是的。我认为，这也有一种怨恨和屈辱感，因为当爱娃还不到一岁时，杜阿尔特就说：“我在这个可怜的小镇待够了。我要回到我真正的家人身边了。”于是他又回到了他真正的家人那里，那是在一个叫做奇维尔科伊（Chivilcoy）地方。
and they weren't kind of legally entitled to. So right from the start, there's a sort of a taint, I suppose. Her parents are unmarried, but then she's using a name that is not her own. But also a sense of moving up, of aspiring, of wanting something better than what you were born into. Exactly, yeah. There's also, I think, a sense of resentment and humiliation because when Eva is not even one, Duarte says, I've had enough of my time working in this pathetic little town. I'm actually going back to my real family. And back he goes to his real family, which is in a place called Chivilcoy.
那是一个中产阶级家庭吗，多米尼克？如果他是一个农场经理，那无论如何也谈不上是精英阶层，但它肯定比伊巴古伦家族更中产阶级。这会激起艾薇塔发出这样的呐喊：“见鬼的中产阶级。我绝不接受他们。我父亲的另一个家庭是中产阶级，而我们被藏在视线之外，在他的葬礼上被藏起来。”这是音乐剧中感人的一幕。如果你要在节目中一直背诵音乐剧的台词，那就会变得很烦人了。我是替听众说的。
And is that a family middle class, Dominic? If he's a farm manager, it's not elite by any stretch of the imagination, but it's certainly more middle class than the Ibargueran family. And so it would inspire Evita to cry, screw the middle classes. I will never accept them. My father's other family were middle class and we were kept out of sight, hidden from view at his funeral. So that's a moving rendition from the musical. If you're going to consistently recite things in the musical, it will become tiresome. I'm speaking for the audience.
不，但这确实是一个重要的方面，不是吗？他去世了。是的。按照习俗，他们是不被允许去参加葬礼的。确实如此。不过我确实认为，唱得太多在编辑上是个失误。我认为你提到它是对的。非常感谢。
No, but that is an important aspect, isn't it? The fact that he dies. Yeah. And by custom, they should not be allowed to go to the funeral. Exactly. Although I do think it would be an editorial error to sing too much. I think you are right to mention it. Thank you very much.
也要向蒂姆·赖斯致敬，他把这一切总结得如此精辟。干得好，蒂姆·赖斯。因为我认为这可能是她一生前10到15年中发生的最具影响力的一件事。当她大约六岁时，她的父亲在一次车祸中丧生。她的母亲胡安娜说：“我要去
And kudos to Tim Rice for summing it up so well. Well done, Tim Rice. Because I think this is probably the single most influential thing that ever happened to her in the first 10, 15 years of her life. When she's about six, her father is killed in a car crash. And Juana, her mother, says, I will go to
葬礼。我们全都要去。”现在，她给孩子们穿上丧服。他们一起去了奇维尔科伊。守灵正在进行中。每个人看到他们都惊恐万分。并不是说他们不知道这些人存在。我想他们知道他们存在，但他们就是不想让这个所谓的第二家庭出现。就像宴席上的幽灵。
the funeral. We will all go. Now, she dresses the children in mourning. They all go to Chivilcoy. The wake is in progress. And everybody is absolutely horrified to see them. It's not that they don't know they exist. I think they know they exist, but they just, they do not want this basically second family turning up. Spectres at the feast.
是的，有很多人在争论，最终达成的妥协是灵车将驶向墓地，他们可以步行，但必须走在最后面，不能和“真正的家庭”（加上引号）走在一起。你知道，那将是一个奇观。他们将当众受辱。我的意思是，每个人都被这一幕羞辱了。这是对阿根廷乡村社会阶层特征的一种提醒。
Yeah. And there's a lot of arguing and eventually the compromise is made that the hearse will proceed to the graveyard and they can walk but right at the back, not with the real family, in averted commas. You know, there'll be a spectacle. They will be publicly humiliated. I mean, everybody's humiliated by this scene. It's a reminder of the kind of the hierarchical character
没错，确实如此。所以爱娃在那个时候一定知道了——六岁，你已经记事了，这件事会对你产生影响——清楚地意识到有人鄙视你，也鄙视你的母亲。显然，在她的余生中，爱娃和她的姐姐们一样，只会对她对不公的愤慨做出一些暗含隐喻的表述：“从我记事起，不公的存在就刺痛着我的灵魂，就像有一枚钉子被钉进里面一样。从我人生的每一个阶段，我都保留着某种折磨我、撕裂我的不公的记忆。”我想这无疑是这一切的核心。
of Argentine rural society. Right, it is. So Ava must know at that point, six, you're old enough to remember this and for this to have an impact on you, to be aware at the very, that there are people who despise you and who despise your mother. And it is clear that for the rest of her life, Ava, like her sisters would just make these sort of coded references to her outrage against injustice. From as far as I can remember, the existence of injustice has hurt my soul as if a nail was being driven into it. From every period of my life, I retain the memory of some injustice tormenting me and tearing me apart. And I think this undoubtedly lies at the heart of
无论如何，他们回到了洛斯托尔多斯。她是一个非常瘦小的小女孩。他们叫她“瘦子”（la flaca）。当她大约10、11岁时，他们最终搬到了一个稍微大一点的地方，叫做胡宁（Junin），那是一个铁路交汇处。多米尼克，据说这个名字源自克丘亚语中的“平原”。哦，那挺好的。所以它有点平坦，对吧？
it all. So they go back to Los Tolos anyway. She is a very skinny, small little girl. They call her skinny, la flaca, the thin one. They end up moving eventually when she's about 10, 11, to a slightly bigger place called Junin, which is a kind of railway junction. It apparently, Dominic, derives from the Quecha word for plains. Oh, that's nice. So it's kind of flat, isn't it?
没什么可玩的。尘土飞扬、有些破烂、没有铺砌的道路。那是狂野的西部。是的，有点像狂野西部。她在胡宁上学。后来，一位老师回忆起她时说：“一个非常美丽的小女孩，有着黑色的头发、如瓷器般的皮肤、一个非常自我沉浸的孩子，有着丰富的内心世界、
Not a lot to do. Dusty, sort of scruffy, unpaved roads. It's Wild West. Yeah, a little bit Wild West. She goes to school in Hunin. One of the teachers remembers her later and says, a very beautiful little girl with dark hair, skin like porcelain, a very self-absorbed child with an intense inner life,
极大的敏感和极大的脆弱。”当然，对于这种回忆，你永远不知道其中有多少是后见之明的投射，对吧？我是说，也许那位老师根本不记得了。看来他们再次陷入了那种状态——没有丈夫，没有父亲，他们的头顶上悬着一层淡淡的阴云，有些女孩被告知不要跟那些自称为杜阿尔特的人说话，所以母亲依然自称为杜阿尔特遗孀。
great sensitivity and great vulnerability. Of course, you never know with this how much this is back projection do you i mean maybe that teacher doesn't even remember at all it seems that they again were you know there's no husband no father there's a slight sort of cloud hanging over them some girls are told you don't talk to their duartes as they're calling themselves so the mother is calling herself the widow duarte exactly and she's still very keen on kind of projecting respectability. And she's raising her girls and her son Juan to think of themselves as respectable. Yeah. But there's the challenge, obviously, of how do you maintain that facade if you don't actually
没错，她依然非常热衷于塑造体面感。她把女儿们和儿子胡安抚养长大，让他们认为自己是有尊严的。是的。但显而易见的问题是：如果你实际上没有钱，又该如何维持这种表面风光呢？是的，他们确实没有。所以母亲做了很多针纫活，不是吗？缝纫机后来成了艾薇塔的一个重要标志。是的。而且她还收留房客。
have any money? No, which they don't. So the mother, she sews a lot, doesn't she? And sewing machines will become a kind of important icon for Evita later on. Yeah. And she takes in lodgers. She takes in lodgers and she cooks for them. And this will provide a lot of scope for anti-Evita propagandists later on.
她收留房客并为他们做饭。这为后来反艾薇塔的宣传人员提供了大量的素材。
Yeah. Because the story, and it's one that Jorge Luis Borges, the great writer who we've already mentioned, he says that she was running a brothel and that she was pimping out the girls. I mean, this is simply not true at all, is it? No, it's not true. There is no foundation for that whatsoever. It's the opposite. I mean, big spoiler. Ava Perron, I think, was never a prostitute. I think it's often claimed that she was, but I don't think she was. I think they are actually quite the opposite. As
因为这个故事——我们已经提到过的大作家豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯也说过——说她开过妓院，还拉皮条把这些女孩推向火坑。我的意思是，这完全不是真的，对吧？不，这不是真的。这没有任何根据。事实恰恰相反。我的意思是，最大的剧透是：爱娃·庇隆，我认为她从来都不是妓女。人们经常声称她是，但我认为她不是。我认为恰恰相反。正如
you say, I think they are obsessed with respectability. Yeah. It is something that is always out of reach and they're desperate to reach it. The thing that I think Ava thinks about more than anything when she's growing up, like a lot of people, is, you know, where are we? We are in the 1930s. This is the age of the cinema. So there's a cinema. There were multiple cinemas actually in Hunin.
你所说的那样，我认为他们对体面有着近乎执着的追求。是的。那是他们总是触不可及却又拼命想要得到的东西。我想爱娃在成长过程中思考得最多的事情，和许多人一样，就是：“我们在哪里？我们身处20世纪30年代。这是电影的时代。”所以那里有电影院。胡宁其实有多家电影院。
The great biography of Ava Perron by Nicholas Fraser and Marisa Navarro. She says, you know, every week they go and see these films. And on the films are images of a European or North American life, depictions of wealth and power, visions of great and glittering cities, and most of all, of love. Love across class barriers, love and money, love and furs, love and destiny. Yeah, it is by this point chiefly American films. Yeah. Because the Argentine film industry has basically been decimated by the rise of speakeas. And the Americans have kind of imposed a ban on the sale of cine film. Well, also, I think the Argentine film industry, those people who are sort of historians of Argentine cinema may object to this. But I think there's a sense that in the 1930s, actually, it's not very good.
尼古拉斯·弗雷泽（Nicholas Fraser）和玛丽莎·纳瓦罗（Marisa Navarro）合著的爱娃·庇隆的伟大传记中说：“每周他们都去看这些电影。电影里呈现的是欧洲或北美生活的影像，是对财富和权力的描绘，是宏伟闪耀城市的幻景，而最重要的是，还有爱情。跨越阶级的爱、爱与金钱、爱与皮草、爱与命运。”是的，到这个时候，基本上都是美国电影了。是的，因为阿根廷电影产业基本上已经被有声电影的兴起摧毁了。而且美国人基本上禁止了电影胶片的销售。不过，我认为，研究阿根廷电影史的人可能会对此提出异议。但我觉得在20世纪30年代，实际上阿根廷电影并不算出色。
Yeah. I mean, it's in decline at this point. Now, Ava is like a lot of girls. She loves the cinema. She loves music and dancing. She dreams of a life in show business. And ultimately, when she's 15 years old, she persuades her mother to let her move to Buenos Aires to seek her fortune in this world.
我的意思是，它当时正在衰落。现在，爱娃和许多女孩一样。她喜欢电影。她喜欢音乐和跳舞。她梦想着过上娱乐圈的生活。最终，在她15岁时，她劝说母亲让她搬到布宜诺斯艾利斯，在这个世界里寻找发迹的机会。
Because you mentioned her love of dancing. And of course, the famous Argentine dance is the tango. Yeah. And the story is that it's not her mother who takes her to Buenos Aires, but a tango singer. Isn't that right? Yes. Agustin Magaldi, who was actually one of the biggest tango singers in Argentina. A.K.A. Jimmy Nail. Of course, it's Jimmy Nail in the film. It's Jimmy Nail in the film. Yeah. So Magaldi looked nothing like Jimmy Nail in reality. No,K.A. Jimmy Nail. Of course, it's Jimmy Nail in the film. It's Jimmy Nail in the film. Yeah. So, Mugaldi looked nothing like Jimmy Nail in reality. No, he didn't.
因为你提到了她对舞蹈的热爱，而阿根廷著名的舞蹈当然是探戈。是的。故事是说，带她去布宜诺斯艾利斯的不是她母亲，而是一位探戈歌手。是这样的吗？是的。奥古斯丁·马加尔迪（Agustin Magaldi），他实际上是阿根廷最著名的探戈歌手之一。也就是吉米·内尔。当然，电影里演的就是吉米·内尔。电影里就是吉米·内尔。是的。所以，马加尔迪在现实中长得一点也不像吉米·内尔。不，他不像。
But also, he's not a kind of classic tango singer, is he? Because he's much more concerned with social issues. He's very passionate about social justice. And I always wondered whether this story emerges because the themes of his songs are seen to kind of map onto Ava's later concerns. I don't know what you think about that. No, I think that's a fair point because his music, his lyrics echo the themes of her rhetoric. Yeah. So you'll see this a lot. It's definitely a thing in the musical, the Andrew Lloyd Webber music, Tim Rice musical. There's a story that Agustin Magaldi came to
而且，他也不是那种传统的探戈歌手，对吧？因为他更关心社会问题。他对社会公正充满热情。我一直好奇这个故事的出现，是因为他的歌曲主题被认为与爱娃后来的关切不谋而合。不知道你对此怎么看？不，我认为这是一个合理的观点，因为他的音乐、他的歌词与她的言辞主题相呼应。是的。所以你会经常看到这一点。这绝对是音乐剧中的一个元素，安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯和蒂姆·赖斯创作的音乐剧。有这样一个故事：奥古斯丁·马加尔迪来到
Junín to perform. He's a great hit. And then he takes her back with him to Buenos Aires, effectively as his mistress. But her biographers say this is rubbish. First of all, there's actually no evidence he ever came to Hunin at all. But also, he travels with his wife. His wife comes on tour. It is highly implausible that his wife would approve of him with this very skinny, and she's not exactly a bombshell, young ava that his wife would smile meekly while he brings her back with them to the capital i think that's very unlikely yeah what it actually obviously expresses is one that suspicion that you've already said that basically the family are all prostitutes and that she only advances because of her sexuality which i don't think is right at
胡宁演出。他大获成功。然后他把她和自己一起带回了布宜诺斯艾利斯，实际上是当成了他的情妇。但她的传记作者说这是无稽之谈。首先，实际上没有任何证据表明他去过胡宁。其次，他出行时带着他的妻子。他的妻子也随团巡演。他的妻子绝不可能允许他带着这个非常瘦弱——而且她绝不是什么性感尤物——的年轻爱娃，并且当他把她和他们一起带回首都时，他的妻子还能温顺地微笑，我认为这极其不可能。
all and secondly i totally agree with you the sense in some mysterious way her life and career must be bound up with the tango which is the one thing that people know about argentine culture in the early 20th century tango of course is born in brothels in the port of buenos aires then it becomes a bit more respectable goes to paris and so on the tango is melancholy its themes are kind of generally love and suffering and sacrifice. And actually, as we will see, those are the themes of Eva Peron's politics. They are rhetorical themes that she goes on about. Yeah.
是的，这实际上明显表达了一种猜疑，也就是你刚才已经说过的：这个家族基本上都是妓女，她之所以能平步青云完全是因为她的性吸引力，我认为这根本不对。其次，我完全同意你的看法，那就是在某种神秘的意义上，她的人生和职业生涯必然与探戈联系在一起，这是20世纪初人们对阿根廷文化唯一的了解。探戈当然诞生于布宜诺斯艾利斯港口的妓院，后来变得体面了一些，传到了巴黎等等。探戈充满忧郁，它的主题通常是爱、痛苦和牺牲。事实上，正如我们将要看到的，这些正是伊娃·庇隆政治的主题。它们是她滔滔不绝阐述的修辞主题。是的。
So she's undoubtedly steeped in the world of the tango. I mean, that music is playing all the time. I mean, it is the sound of Buenos Aires. And the realm of film is also that of great cities like Buenos Aires. So obviously, if you are the kind of girl who doesn't want to be stuck in Hicksville, who dreams of the bright lights and you are in the middle of Argentina, Buenos Aires is the only place to go. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will follow Ava to the Big Apple.
所以她无疑沉浸在探戈的世界里。我的意思是，那种音乐一直在播放。我的意思是，那就是布宜诺斯艾利斯的声音。而电影的领域也是像布宜诺斯艾利斯这样伟大城市的领域。所以很显然，如果你是一个不想被困在偏远小镇、梦想着灿烂霓虹灯而又身处阿根廷内陆的女孩，布宜诺斯艾利斯就是你唯一的去处。所以我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将跟随爱娃前往“大苹果”。
Very good. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
非常好。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. What's new a Buenos Aires? As Evita famously sang when arriving in the streets of the great Argentine capital city. And Dominic, she's 15. Yeah.
如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。布宜诺斯艾利斯有什么新鲜事？正如艾薇塔在踏入这座伟大的阿根廷首都街头时那首著名的歌唱所说的那样。多米尼克，她当时15岁。是的。
She has no money. She has no particular education or aptitudes. What is life like for someone with no particular skills turning up in this massive city? Overwhelming, Tom. Terrifying, actually. So Ava is one of many, many people who are at this point arriving in Buenos Aires from the interior of Argentina and moving off the land and into the city. So Buenos Aires in the 19th century
她没有钱。她没有特殊的教育背景或天赋。对于一个没有什么特殊技能却来到这座庞大城市的人来说，生活是怎样的？压倒一切的，汤姆。实际上，那是极其可怕的。所以爱娃是此时从阿根廷内陆抵达布宜诺斯艾利斯、离开土地涌入城市的成千上万的人之一。因此，19世纪的布宜诺斯艾利斯
had been quite a small place. It has expanded massively. It's a city of immigrants. So its population is about 2.5 million, rising towards 3 million, full of Italians and Basques who have come across the Atlantic in the last couple of decades.
原本是一个相当小的城市。它已经大规模扩张。这是一座移民城市。因此它的人口大约是250万，正朝着300万迈进，到处都是在过去几十年里横渡大西洋而来的意大利人和巴斯克人。
I guess a way to think about it, especially for American and Canadian listeners, it's basically a combination of New York and Chicago. So it's's meat packing i know you love meat packing tom and speakeasies yeah two things very close to your heart it's the center of the railway network so it's full of trains and stations it's full of kind of abattoirs this is where they freeze the meat this is the meat on which argentina's got rich and they send it across the Atlantic. It's full of banks, there's a stock exchange, there are opera houses, all built in a kind of European baron houseman, late 19th century Parisian style. So it looks like, in some ways, a sort of alternative universe version of Paris
我想，对于美国和加拿大的听众来说，理解它的一个好方法是，它基本上就是纽约和芝加哥的结合体。所以这里有肉类加工厂——我知道你喜欢肉类加工厂，汤姆——还有地下酒吧。这两样东西都贴近你的心脏。它是铁路网的中心，所以到处都是火车和车站，到处都是屠宰场，肉类就在这里被冷冻，这就是阿根廷致富的肉类，然后它们被运往大西洋彼岸。这里到处都是银行，有证券交易所，有歌剧院，全部按照19世纪末巴黎式的欧洲奥斯曼男爵风格建造。所以从某些方面来看，它看起来就像是巴黎的平行宇宙版本，
in which the elite behave as though they're on Bond Street in London. Now, obviously, most people are not part of that elite. So there's a huge working class, largely immigrant. The Italians and the Basques came at the turn of the century. Now there are lots of people like Evita coming from the interior, and they are working in factories and shops on the outskirts of Buenos Aires, and they're often living in very, very poor, cramped, insalubrious conditions. So that is her milieu.
这里的精英们表现得好像他们身处伦敦的邦德街一样。当然，大多数人并不是那个精英阶层的一部分。所以这里有一个庞大的工人阶层，很大程度上由移民组成。意大利人和巴斯克人在世纪之交来到这里。现在有很多像艾薇塔这样来自内陆的人来到这里，他们在布宜诺斯艾利斯郊区的工厂和商店工作，而且他们往往生活在非常贫困、拥挤、卫生条件糟糕的环境中。所以这就是她的环境。
She will be spending the next few years drifting around these kind of pensiones, these like, you know, boarding houses, lodging houses, you know, crowded, miserable, probably frightening, frankly, for a girl in her teens. But at the same time, kind of exciting. Oh, totally. Yeah, definitely. And she has got away from the controlling presence of her mother as well. Yeah. Which must also, I mean, if you're independently minded, which Ava clearly is, that must also be a factor, don't you think? And must have steeled her to continue to remain in the city, to not kind of give up, to not
她将在接下来的几年里在这些被称为“彭西奥内”（pensiones）的地方四处漂泊，也就是寄宿公寓、旅馆，拥挤、悲惨，坦率地说，对于一个十几岁的女孩来说可能非常可怕。但与此同时，又让人感到兴奋。哦，完全是这样。是的，绝对如此。而且她也摆脱了母亲那种具有控制力的存在。是的。如果你是一个思想独立的人——爱娃显然就是这样的人——这也是一个重要的因素，你不觉得吗？并且这一定坚定了她继续留在城市里、不轻言放弃、不退缩的决心
go back. Yeah, most people would go back though. So as our biographers say, everybody dreams of a life in the big city and life and showbiz and being on the stage and being in front of a camera. Except for you, Dominic. Well, maybe I have my dreams too,
回去吧。是的，不过大多数人还是会回去的。正如我们的传记作家所说，每个人都梦想着在大城市生活，梦想着演艺圈的生活，梦想着登上舞台，梦想着面对镜头。除了你，多米尼克。好吧，也许我也有我的梦想，
Tom. You know, I still dream of that little, you know, the Hollywood agent getting in touch. Yeah, I suppose. Yeah.
汤姆。你知道的，我依然梦想着那个，你知道的，好莱坞经纪人主动联系我。对，我想是吧。对。
You know, Eurovision is not closed off to me entirely. So, you know, most people dream of that, but settle down in their little town. There's something in her, the drive. There is undoubtedly a drive because there are no sources about this time. We don't have evidence for it, but the evidence is her life, I guess. I think what she sees in Buenos Aires is the possibility of another life. So I mentioned the elite.
你知道，欧洲对我来说并不是完全关上大门。所以，你知道的，大多数人都有那样的梦想，但在他们的小镇上安顿下来。她身上有一种东西，那种进取心。毫无疑问，她有一种进取心，因为关于这段时间没有什么资料。我们没有证据，但证据就是她的人生，我猜。我认为她在布宜诺斯艾利斯看到的是另一种生活的可能性。所以我提到了精英阶层。
The elite are impossibly rich, even by European standards. So there's an amazing statistic that in 1930, the top 2,000 people in Argentina owned land that was the equivalent to Holland, Belgium, and Switzerland put together. I don't know why you'd put those three countries together. But anyway, that's the equivalent of the land holdings of this elite. And these are people who made the money in the 19th century. They're the old families. They live like English country gentlemen and ladies.
精英阶层富得流油，即使按欧洲标准来看也是如此。因此有一个惊人的统计数据：在1930年，阿根廷最顶层的2000人拥有的土地相当于荷兰、比利时和瑞士加起来的总和。我不知道你为什么要把这三个国家放在一起。但无论如何，这相当于这些精英们的土地持有量。这些人是在19世纪发家致富的。他们是老牌家族。他们的生活就像英国的乡绅和淑女一样。
They play polo. They play croquet. They shop at Harrods, which has a branch in Buenos Aires. They go to the Opera House, the Teatro Colón. They go to the Jockey Club, which is the gentleman's club. Yeah, the watering holes of the well-to-do. And in the Argentine winter, which is our summer, they would go to Europe, to the Côte d'Azur, to summer on the Italian lakes, to go to the races in England. And people would say,
他们打马球。他们打槌球。他们在哈罗德百货公司购物，该百货公司在布宜诺斯艾利斯设有分店。他们去歌剧院，即科隆剧院。他们去赛马俱乐部，这是一个绅士俱乐部。是的，富人们的消遣去处。在阿根廷的冬天，也就是我们的夏天，他们会去欧洲，去蔚蓝海岸，去意大利的湖泊度夏，去英国看赛马。人们会说，
oh my God, Argentines are so rich. They're not country cousins. They're nouveau riche, I suppose. So in Paris, there was an expression at the time to be as rich as an Argentine. So these are the people that she is looking up to, I think. Well, she's not looking up to them, though, is she? She despises them. She hates them precisely because she is looking up to them, though, surely. That's why she hates them, because they are at the top of that pyramid. Yeah, but looking up to them implies that they provide her with the standard. No, you're right. She wants to displace them.
哦天哪，阿根廷人太有钱了。他们可不是什么乡下亲戚。我想，他们是暴发户。所以在当时的巴黎，有一个表达是“像阿根廷人一样富有”。所以这些人就是她仰望的对象，我认为。不过，她并没有仰望他们，不是吗？她鄙视他们。她恨他们，恰恰是因为她在仰望他们，当然。这就是她恨他们的原因，因为他们位于金字塔的顶端。是的，但是仰望他们意味着他们为她提供了标准。不，你说得对。她想要取代他们。
She absolutely does. Yeah. But, I mean, important to say that at this point, she's not politically minded at all, is she? No, not at all. her with the standard no you're right she wants to displace them she absolutely does yeah but i mean important to say that at this point she's not politically minded at all is she no not at all she has no real interest in um kind of social issues and she's entirely focused on making her way as an actress she is and to begin with i mean she's not a very good actress is part of the problem no and her earliest roles even on stage she's part of the lower classes she's always playing maids or secretaries rather than queens or anything she is she's in terrible plays that
她绝对是这么想的。是的。但是，我的意思是，必须要说的是，在这一点上，她一点也没有政治头脑，不是吗？不，完全没有。对她来说...不，你说的对，她想取代他们，她绝对是这么想的，是的。但我的意思是，必须指出的是，在这一点上，她一点也没有政治头脑，不是吗？不，完全没有。她对诸如...之类的事没有真正的兴趣。社会问题，她完全专注于作为一名演员闯荡出路。她的确是，而且一开始，我的意思是她并不是一个很好的演员，这是问题的一部分。不，她最早的角色，甚至在舞台上，她也是社会底层的人，她总是扮演女佣或秘书，而不是女王或别的什么。她的确是，她演的都是那些糟糕的剧本，
run for two weeks and are never heard of again and we only get like fragmentary glimpses of her life so she's in a play about a girl school and somebody says young very pretty dark eyes the personification of innocence she seems very pure that's her persona at this point of course because she's 15 16 yeah there's also a glimpse we have of her she goes to some friends at some point to the beach in montevideo montevideo the capital of uruguay and there are boys who see her on the beach upper class boys and one of them said later i remember her she seemed neither stupid nor intelligent perfectly unremarkable and rather lower class and that rather lower class, that's the tone.
只演两个星期就再也听不见了，我们对她生活的了解只有一些零碎的片段。所以她演过一部关于女子学校的戏剧，有人说：年轻、非常漂亮、黑眼睛、纯洁的化身，她看起来非常清纯。这正是她当时的人设，当然，因为她当时15、16岁。是的，我们对她还有另一个了解的片段，她曾在某个时候和一些朋友去乌拉圭首都蒙得维的亚的海滩，蒙得维的亚是乌拉圭的首都，那里有男孩子在海滩上看到她，上流社会的男孩子，其中一个人后来还说，我记得她，她看起来既不愚蠢也不聪明，极其平庸，而且相当有下层阶级的风范。而那种下层阶级的风范，就是那种基调。
So is that the place that she's gone with this rather sinister sounding guy, Pablo Suero, aka the Toad? Yes. Yeah. And it's said of him that she is sleeping with him. Which she probably was. Because we've said that she's not a prostitute. Yeah.
所以，那是她和那个听起来很不祥的家伙巴勃罗·苏埃罗（Pablo Suero），也就是人称“蟾蜍”的人一起去的地方吗？是的。是的。人们传说她和他睡过觉。她很可能确实如此。因为我们说过她不是妓女。是的。
But anyone listening and thinking, you know know attractive young girl wanting to make her way as an actress in a very very predatory and masculine dominated world i mean it seems improbable that the directors with the power would not have leveraged their control of course and i don't think even the most sympathetic biographer would doubt that in a way that we undoubtedly would find repellent now in the kind of Me Too era. Well, because there's this famous kind of, so after Suero and Evita split up, she goes to ask him for another part. That's right. And he keeps her sitting outside, you know, the office for hours and hours. And then he kind of bounds out of the office and yells at her.
但是任何听到这里的人都会想，你知道的，一个有吸引力的年轻女孩，想在一个非常具有掠夺性和由男性主导的世界里成为一名演员，我的意思是，拥有权力的导演不可能不利用他们的控制权，这似乎不太可能，当然，即使是最富有同情心的传记作家也不会怀疑这一点，以一种我们在如今的“Me Too”时代毫无疑问会觉得令人反感的方式。嗯，因为有一个著名的...所以在苏埃罗和埃维塔分手后，她去找他要另一个角色。没错。而他让她在办公室外面等了几个小时又几个小时。然后他从办公室里冲出来，冲她大吼。
Do you think that because I slept with you, I'm always obliged to give you work? Very publicly in front of all the other actresses. Yes. There are loads of other actresses there. And the person who sees it says her voice became softer and softer. She became whiter and whiter with humiliation again. A terrible scene. And even if that one incident didn't happen,
你以为我和你睡过，就必须一直给你安排工作吗？非常公开地在所有其他女演员面前。是的。那里有大批其他女演员。目睹这一幕的人说，她的声音变得越来越轻。在羞辱面前，她的脸色变得越来越苍白。又是一个可怕的场景。即使那一次事件没有发生，
there must have been many such incidents. Yeah. And you can see why in due course, she will want to erase the record of her career as an actress as well as her origins completely from the record. Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. Which obviously then makes it difficult to know what was going on. Exactly. We do have a sense, I think, of what was going on because people have dug into the listings and things. We know that she was in a terrible radio science fiction program in a tiny part we know that she entered a beauty
也一定有过很多这样的事件。是的。你可以理解为什么在适当的时候，她会想要抹去自己作为演员的职业生涯记录，以及她的出身记录。是的，绝对的。绝对的。这显然让人很难弄清楚当时到底发生了什么。确实如此。我们确实有一种感觉，我认为当时发生了什么，因为人们已经深入挖掘了各种节目单和资料。我们知道她在一个糟糕的科幻广播节目里演了一个极小的角色，我们知道她参加了一个选美
contest and lost it that she was the mc of a kind of tango competition that she was an extra in a film about boxing and we know that she's she's listed in stage programs but you know she's in the chorus or she has no lines or she has one line she must have been very very poor i don't mean a poor actress i mean you know no money i mean one point of contact that she does have is her brother juan who is in buenos aires as well yeah and he's kind of he's a slightly shady character isn't he he is and later on he will be accused of gross corruption i think not entirely unfairly so she does have her brother but that avails her very little one of the actresses who she worked with, the lead actress in a play, a woman called Pierina D'Alessi, she took her under her wing a bit.
比赛但输了，她曾是一种探戈比赛的主持人，她曾在一部关于拳击的电影里跑龙套，我们知道她被列在舞台演出名单中，但你知道，她只是在合唱队里，或者她没有台词，或者她只有一句台词。她一定非常非常穷，我不是指她是个差劲的演员，我是指你知道的，身无分文。我的意思是，她确实有一个联系人，那就是她的弟弟胡安，他也身处布宜诺斯艾利斯。是的，他有点像个不太正派的人物，不是吗？他是的，后来他将被指控犯有严重的腐败罪，我认为这并非完全不公。所以她确实有她弟弟，但这并没有给她带来多大帮助。有一个和她合作过的女演员，是一部戏里的女主角，一个叫皮里娜·达莱西（Pierina D'Alessi）的女人，她对她照顾有加。
And she later said, I remember her. She was hungry, unhappy, careless about herself. Her hands were cold and sweaty. She would come to the theatre early because it was warmer than her room and she had nowhere else to go. A sad scene, but one that you can completely imagine. You know, such a common story. And there's another record, I can't remember who it is, who is saying to her, why don't you improve your elocution?
她后来回忆说：“我记得她。她很饿，很不快乐，对自己的外表毫不在意。她的手又冷又汗。她总是很早就来到剧院，因为那里比她的房间暖和，而且她无处可去。”这是一个悲伤的场景，但也是一个完全可以想象的场景。你知道，这是一个多么常见的故事。还有另一个记录，我不记得是谁了，曾对她说：“你为什么不提高一下你的发音技巧呢？”
Because she has a very working class accent, very provincial accent. She mispronounces a lot of words. And the friend is saying, why don't you try and improve your ability to speak so that you will get better parts? And she kind of says, I just, I can't. I just haven't got the energy for it yeah she's always hungry always tired yeah she's too tired too hungry even to do that and actually also tom let us be honest she's not actually very good she's not a
因为她有着浓重的工人阶级口音，非常地方化的口音。她有很多单词发音都不准确。朋友对她说：“你为什么不试着提高你的口语能力，这样就能接到更好的角色呢？”她有点回答说：“我只是，我做不到。我实在没有精力去做这件事。”是的，她总是饥肠辘辘，总是疲惫不堪。是的，她太累了，太饿了，连这都做不到。事实上，汤姆，让我们老实说，她其实并不是很好，她不是一个
great actress she's not stunningly beautiful although her style of acting actually turns out to be quite effective on the radio yes and this is really the making of her isn't it it is completely you're absolutely right so in 1939 i mean she would be hanging around all the time outside the offices of agents and producers and things and she seems to have got in with a group who were going to produce a whole series of plays by this playwright called hector blomberg and she actually manages to land a role as one of the stars of this series. She's about 19, and the first thing they're going to do
伟大的演员，她也不是惊艳的美女，尽管她的表演风格在广播里其实相当有效。是的，这确实是她成功的转折点，不是吗？完全是这样，你完全没说错。所以在1939年，我的意思是她总是闲逛在经纪人和制片人等人的办公室外面，她似乎和一群人混在了一起，这群人打算制作一系列由这位名叫赫克托·布隆伯格（Hector Blomberg）的剧作家创作的戏剧，她实际上设法争取到了这个系列剧主演之一的角色。她当时大约19岁，他们要做的第一件事
is this love story in 19th century, late 19th century, Belle Epoque kind of Paris. And it's the first time that she really gets any publicity, and she is going to become a bit of a radio star. Now, I think that this is absolutely central in the making of her, not just as a show business personality, but as a political personality. Argentine radio is not nothing. It's the second biggest commercial network in the world.
就是这个19世纪的爱情故事，背景是19世纪末的美好年代（Belle Epoque）时期的巴黎。这是她第一次真正获得任何公开知名度，她将成为一个小有名气的广播明星。现在，我认为这对于她塑造自己绝对是核心的，不仅作为演艺界名人，而且作为政治人物。阿根廷的广播可不是小打小闹。它是世界第二大商业广播网。
So the biggest is the US. And in this vast country, far bigger than any European country and incredibly underpopulated. So people are living gigantic distances from each other. The radio has this almost supernatural power over people and particularly soap operas, which are broadcast every evening at 530 to women preparing the dinner for their husbands to come home. And they're called soap operas because basically they're sponsored by soap manufacturers. Yes. And you mentioned Reagan earlier. I mean, there's an echo there.
所以最大的是美国。在这个辽阔的国家里，比任何欧洲国家都要大得多，而且人口极其稀少。所以人们居住的距离非常遥远。广播对人们有着几乎超自然的力量，特别是肥皂剧，每天晚上5:30播出，正是女人们准备晚饭等丈夫回家的时候。它们被称为肥皂剧，因为基本上是由肥皂制造商赞助的。是的。你刚才提到了里根。我的这里面有一种回响。
Reagan kind of cuts his political teeth, doesn't he? By selling fridges, essentially. Yeah, General Electric. And there's a sense in which Ava's ability to act effectively as a radio star is also about selling stuff. I mean, she's selling soap as well. Yeah, she is. And so that idea of broadcasting messages is something like Reagan,
里根的政治触觉是通过卖冰箱磨练出来的，不是吗？是的，通用电气。某种意义上，伊娃作为广播明星有效表演的能力，也与推销商品有关。我的意思是，她也在卖肥皂。是的，她确实在卖。所以传播信息的这种想法就像里根一样，
that she is learning by doing this. It's the intersection of capitalism and acting, I guess. It is. When we did the Reagan series, I remember we were talking a lot about Reagan and Hollywood. And I said, I always thought, like Lou Cannon, Reagan's great biographer, that it's bonkers that people would say of Reagan, he's just an actor. Because being an actor is brilliant preparation for politics. Saying the lines, wearing the makeup, standing in the right place, meeting the fans, all of that. And I think radio ditto with politics in Argentina. So the way it would work in Argentina is because there are lots of people who are very poor in these far-flung villages, the radio manufacturers would get trucks and they would send them to these villages
她通过这样做来进行学习。我想，这是资本主义和表演的交汇点。确实如此。当我们做里根系列节目时，我记得我们谈了很多关于里根和好莱坞的话题。我说过，我一直认为，就像里根伟大的传记作家卢·坎农（Lou Cannon）一样，人们说里根“他只是个演员”是极其荒谬的。因为当演员是通往政治的绝佳准备。说台词，化装，站在正确的位置，见粉丝，所有这些。我认为广播对于阿根廷的政治来说也是如此。所以在阿根廷运作的方式是，因为在这些偏远的村庄里有很多人非常贫穷，广播制造商会买卡车，把它们派到这些村庄，
and they would have loudspeakers and they would play the soap operas to the people in the village. And the soap operas, as her biographers, Fraser and Navarro, say, the soap operas, they were more recitals of a script than they were dramas. So the script would have been written just beforehand. The entire thing is at an absolute kind of pitch of emotion yeah histrionic almost histrionic from the start to the end and it's always about love disappointment sacrifice the lead characters are young women who are always being betrayed or sacrificing themselves for their husbands or whatever but. But who, in the long run, finish up in the arms of a handsome and dashing hero.
他们会有扩音器，把肥皂剧放给村里的人听。正如她的传记作家弗雷泽（Fraser）和纳瓦罗（Navarro）所说，肥皂剧与其说是戏剧，不如说是剧本的朗诵。所以剧本是在刚才才写好的。整件事情都处于一种绝对的情绪高潮中。是的，近乎矫情，从头到尾都矫情，而且总是围绕着爱情、失望、牺牲。主角是年轻女性，总是被背叛，或者为了丈夫做出牺牲等等，但是。
Yes. And these are the roles that Ava is playing. The girl who is poor, who suffers, who endures, but who does, in the long run, get a man. And it's the only role, really, she ever plays. I mean, that's the thing. It's not like this is one role among many. This is all she can do. People said of her voice, I mean, we were talking were talking weren't we about her voice before we started recording
但是，从长远来看，她们最终落入了一个英俊潇洒的英雄的怀抱。是的。而这些就是伊娃扮演的角色。那个贫穷、遭受苦难、坚韧不拔，但最终确实得到了一个男人的女孩。这真的是她唯一扮演过的角色。我的意思是，这就是关键所在。这不像是众多角色中的一个。这就是她所能做的全部。人们对她的声音评价说，我的意思是，我们之前在录音前谈论过她的声音，
her voice is unbelievably monotonous and all she can do is to sort of emote plaintively about duty love sacrifice blah blah martyrdom but she does it incredibly well yeah so that what by 1943 she's earning a fair amount of money and she's able to buy a place. I think she also helped out Juan, who's got gambling debts. Yes. So she's starting to get a degree of security in a way that she had never before in her life had. And she's doing it by playing this role of, you know, the girl who suffers, who then gets her man. And Dominic, would it be fair to say that reality maps onto art? It does indeed. It's extraordinary how in this story, again and again, the soap operas anticipate what is to follow. Because in January 1944, she goes to a gala event where she meets the man with whom her life will be forever entwined. And this is the rising star of Argentine politics,
她的声音单调得令人难以置信，她唯一能做的就是就责任、爱、牺牲等等苦难发出一声声凄凉的情感宣泄，但她做得非常出色。是的，以至于到1943年，她赚了一笔可观的钱，并且能够买下一个住处。我想她还接济了有赌债的胡安。是的。因此，她开始获得某种程度的安全感，这是她一生中从未有过的。而她是通过扮演这样一个角色来做到这一点的，你知道的，那个受苦受难、最终得到自己男人的女孩。多米尼克，把现实映射到艺术上，这样说公平吗？确实如此。不可思议的是，在这个故事中，肥皂剧一次又一次地预示了接下来将要发生的事情。因为在1944年1月，她去参加了一个盛大的活动，在那里她遇到了一个将与她的生命永远交织在一起的男人。这就是阿根廷政坛的新星，
matinee idol, Colonel Juan Domingo Perón. Perón. So I think on that thrilling soap opera-esque moment, we should stop this episode and we will come back next time with the seismic meeting of Eva and Perón. And you can either wait for it if you are a de camisado, if you are one of the suffering poor of Argentina.
少女杀手、胡安·多明戈·佩隆（Juan Domingo Perón）上校。佩隆。我想在这个激动人心的、带有肥皂剧色彩的时刻，我们应该结束这一集，我们下次将带着伊娃和佩隆的震撼性会面归来。如果你是一个“脱衬衫者”（descamisado），如果你是阿根廷饱受苦难的穷人之一，你可以选择等待它。
Don't be mad. But if you want to be a member of the Buenos Aires elite, part of the snooty country clubs, you can, of course, hear it on therstishistory.com by going there and signing up or if you already remember, brilliant. So we will see you whenever. I hope you've enjoyed it and hasta luego. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
别生气。但如果你想成为布宜诺斯艾利斯精英阶层的一员，成为那些自命不凡的乡村俱乐部的一员，你当然可以在 therstisentertainment.com 上收听，只需访问那里并注册，或者如果你已经是会员了，那就太棒了。所以我们随时再见。希望你们喜欢，再见。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票的机会，请前往 therstisentertainment.com。那就是 therstisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。